that k goes back we are doing follow-up
mission or actually to finish it it's
called the x8 data retrieval des now we
get a lot of the stuff we fought like
the crazy dog and ship but now we got
the key to get the mystery the mr. right
what okay baby so that's dad can I do it
how do you like eat them
okay we got the keg
sucking Gabe the [ __ ]
you
let me check this real quick release
unusual specimen into the testing area
well sorry
Ready Steady i do that kid but I gotta
put you down
hey I like how they got that tail I love
tale okay now really how do you [ __ ]
hate it that's all the hell I got a lot
of 8 on sec
okay [ __ ] way tank that's fine I
guess
yeah that's some good [ __ ] here
scrap anything in there now
the [ __ ] is that
a lot of bottle caps a lotta bottle caps
toe box a paint gun [ __ ] is this
okay i'll see this
Oh
basic [ __ ] okay okay it's more [ __ ]
eight though
who do you think is cuter dr. Klein or
dr. burroughs
okay here we go
what is like the weird the witness it's
unusual cuz I'm not gonna worry about
that until
I can get there okay okay here's one
good one chef sucking doc thank you get
a that tail for me [ __ ] [ __ ] no Morstan
pace i knows know where step back okay I
don't think I know that what the [ __ ] is
the unusual creature we're out of
stimpacks maybe we'd be better off with
an autodoc suit
we're out of stimpacks maybe you'd be
better off with an autodoc suit I don't
know what the [ __ ] give you anything
for that injury I thought I don't want
that Oh
did they just like give me one word
today biologists impacts yeah they let
me drop the better off with an autodoc
suit
did there's now
come on her dismissal more stimpacks
there's a socket [ __ ] ok let's
continue we're out of stimpacks maybe
you'd be better off with an autodoc so
ok yeah we heard you like a good first
time yeah dismissal
out of stone backs you here may be
better off with an autodesk okay took a
whole lot of drug so i should have a gut
now right and I say a lot of checks I
need a whole lot of drugs
my [ __ ] excited
[ __ ] what's that ready all right the
[ __ ]
okay if they're not here then they're on
the next floor I thought of that
yeah now next floor
let's check that right yeah a shadow
[ __ ] I'd stop oh [ __ ] no no no no hey
loves Aggie upside i like I said get
that tail dude you got that you got that
tail good I am in love with good that
tail actually [ __ ] I think that water
it's [ __ ] disgusting but [ __ ]
anything in here oh yes alright drink
this baby pygar [ __ ] out I like but
[ __ ] it you know like yellow that was
honey
how can i that's am NOT Zuma
there we go there we go how can I let me
sleep here for a sec oh shut
ah
shadow all right okay total just a new
one on second
oh this is really good
okay i need the sniper cessation of
hostilities complete
Ready Steady ID chase s that guy gotta
go up of stairs can use I don't know if
you guys in here that like wind on the
microphone but I play I playing wind
tunnels can't hear we got stairs what is
unusual creature like a [ __ ]
chupacabra guys max girlfriend like say
why are you betcha ouch ok come on sir
yeah we got here we go come on take a
pocket-sized
can that town yeah Wow by fun
you're my best friend forever okay what
was the onion that guy's dealt with it
was unusual specimen sneaking done
fighting now
oh this is perfect for nine alive
okay all right night stalker back
heck
it's because I took their tails I forgot
[ __ ]
is storage for Josh did you hear me
Betsy Richie likes balls all right I
guess [ __ ] tears again I guess what
the [ __ ] that is but all right
all right way
good good
okay here we go again
bad guys start with time to front [ __ ]
tired
law abiding click missing so pick
okay we're just flying through this now
okay cuz I don't got time for it just to
be Hank I nuts Hannah
man now there's
this [ __ ] I kind of your like to close
a phone we're out of context maybe you'd
be better off than others oh [ __ ] it hey
everything I say that the second ago
I got that town I live that tail you
know nothing sexier than some town
[ __ ] and I
Karen tell rich how does our vet okay
okay
let's say stairs that you stay at last
okay yes yes yes how can Anna isn't I by
tough luck
exercise 1 but there's not [ __ ]
lately
where is that someone just shot the [ __ ]
out of my
he said
the [ __ ] is that about
yeah can I [ __ ] sleep now that Chef I
can jack off see this match chef chef
heck yeah ah scanning there are no
hostile don't you get it what is that
yes oh no we're out of medics the [ __ ]
any other tell some addicts I bet no one
has ever been as unnoticed as me I want
to count it ain't over I guess one up
there
last time i got like killed her yeah
please place this winter shoes in the
city especially those nothing you said
I can ask
your rat tail that [ __ ] now
all right the [ __ ]
they're still more like [ __ ] to do
hmm it's gonna be like a [ __ ] critter
or like hey I'm here I just like miss
one or hell I missed one exit the
testing area what the [ __ ] is there like
um cessation of hostilities complete
time to fight okay oh [ __ ] is right
actually like tied up in on targets
halle [ __ ] where is it
I hear now don't stuck on the door we're
going yeah they can't [ __ ] climb
stairs
writing over I got a lot of aid that so
thank God hi I'm just here to exit
testing center I don't mean any harm
as I can okay
hmm
Wow